bonjour entre faux procès qui reprend
aujourd'hui et sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire on le voit benyamin nétanyahou
cristallise la colère est ce qu'une
démission est envisageable
je pense pas ce qui est certain c'est
que la réunion d'aujourd'hui au tribunal
est une réunion technique d'ailleurs sa
présence n'a pas été obligatoire
il s'agit pour le tribunal pour les
trois personnes qui ont été désignés
pour juger le tribunal et la directrice
d'ailleurs d'un président du tribunal
c'est une dame va l'amener jusqu'à
feldman et elle a pour tâche aujourd'hui
de fixer un programme
alors les avocats font tout pour
reporter pour repousser ce n'est pas
nouveau ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on qui
les ont dès qu'ils ont cette attitude il
s'agit aujourd'hui le estime qu'avec le
corps d'un virus ils ne peuvent pas
travailler avec les masques faire des
procès et donc ils ont demandé à
repousser
ils ont eu satisfaction puisque le
procès réel va débuter en janvier 2021
donc ça laisse un peu de temps ça laisse
un peu de temps à eau aux avocats de
préparer leur dossier
je ne pense pas que à force de repousser
je pense pas que le temps joue pour
netanyahou à l'heure actuelle le temps
est la politique est en sa défaveur
il y à des manifestations presque tous
les jours et on se plaint d'une part de
la gestion du corona mais non pas aussi
mais aussi de la gestion de la
corruption eu des problèmes que
rencontre le premier ministre et il ya
un paradoxe dans cette dans cette
affaire c'est que le premier ministre
est sans arrêt à la télé en train de
dire il n'y a rien dans le dossier il
n'y aura rien dans le dossier ce sont
ses propres termes
elle ne comprend pas pourquoi il a
besoin d'une armada d'avocats il a une
dizaine d'avocats parmi les plus
prestigieux ce qui nécessite pour lui un
budget un budget de 3 millions de
dollars ce n'est pas rien or il a fait
appel à des américains mais ses amis
américains au cours de finance
pas obtenu l'autorisation du tribunal et
donc il est chez lui les français de
financer lui-même toute façon les
chiffres que nous avons montrent que sa
fortune est évaluée à 10 millions de
dollars juste pour les protestataires
dénoncent aussi la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
alors on le rappelle le gouvernement
d'union actuelle a été difficile à
constituer les résultats de très longues
négociations entre benyamin nétanyahou
est grande et benny gantz
aujourd'hui les protestataires accusent
l'ensemble du gouvernement d'être
déconnectés de la réalité
un mot justement peut-être de la
situation économique n'aura dans
laquelle se trouve israël
bon la situation et je dirais dramatique
je pense simplement le cadre d'un petit
sens commercial qui est tout près de
chez moi qui contient à peu près 30
commerces
je me suis promené hier pour préparer
cette émission il ya dix commerces qui
ont fermé marchand de légumes agences
immobilières fringues etc
c'est très grave ils n'ont pas eu le
simplement baisser le rideau
ils ont définitivement quitté les lieux
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas payer le
loyer parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas payer
les petites mains qui travaillent pour
eux et donc c'est là on semble que le
problème fondamental c'est qu'on est en
train de détruire le tissu commercial
elle tissu industriel du pays et on n'a
pas l'air de se rendre compte
c'est pour ça qu'en fait la politique
qui est menée par le gouvernement n'est
pas bonne alors il saupoudre à l'heure
actuelle des dons et saupoudre des aides
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose de très
de très réfléchi
j'en prendrais pour raisons font la
décision la critique du président de la
banque d'israël qui est un président qui
a été nommé par netanyahu lui-même et
qui aujourd'hui critique en perm à lens
le gouvernement en disant que les
nouvelles et les méthodes de piau été
utilisés et les mesures qui ont été
choisis ne sont pas bonnes donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une période
critique
or on ne peut pas fermer tous les
commerces c'est dramatique on ne peut
pas fermer toutes les industries et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on pense
natanyahou agi par intermittences sans
réflexion je prendrais simplement un
exemple il décide de fermer les
restaurants et puis certains
restaurateurs lourd dit écoute
nous avons des stocks de maquereau
remise des stocks de viande de de
nourriture on ne peut pas les jeter
alors nathaniel valley ok on va
prolonger de deux ou trois jours votre
interdiction
cela veut dire que ce sont des décisions
qui sont prises sans concertation avec
les gens sans concertation alors moi ce
qui me gêne un petit peu aussi c'est un
l'opposition l'opposition et est
absolument absente dans ce domaine
seulement dans les rues et c'est là
c'est nouveau c'est que l'opposition
n'est pas à la knesset l'opposition et
dans la rue et c'est grave parce que
quand on est dans la rue on peut avoir
des des problèmes on peut avoir des ddd
des attaques éventuelles contre la
police et c'est ce qui m'inquiète un peu
c'est qu'on passe de la knesset
merci pour votre regard jacques
benillouche le journaliste indépendant
en israël